Endstationen im irgendwo im mikularef
reicht der Strom gerade nicht für die
Straßenbahn plötzlich wurde sie zum
Stillstand verurteilt das schwer
beschädigte Netz hat nicht genügend
Power woanders in der Stadt wird die
Energie dringender gebraucht Paulaner
aber muss an Bord bleiben auch wenn ihre
Passagiere längst zu Fuß weitergezogen
sind
ich sitze hier schon seit 6 Uhr früh
auch wenn wir gerade nicht fahren können
darf ich meinen Arbeitsplatz nicht
verlassen wir Fahrer müssen stets auf
unserem Platz bleiben ich hoffe ich
komme heute noch ins Depot
das ist nicht so schlimm es passieren
noch ganz andere Sachen
viele Menschen müssen ihre Wohnungen
verlassen weil Russlands Luftschläge
ihnen immer wieder Strom und Wärme
nehmen zwischen Steckdosen und
Wasserkochern finden Sie hier Zuflucht
Punkte der Unbesiegbarkeit heißen diese
plastikzelte in denen es schwer fällt an
den Sieg zu glauben
erst musste ich zwei Stunden anstehen
und jetzt warte ich hier schon fast drei
Stunden dass ich mein Handy Akku auflädt
das kostet mich alles unglaublich viel
Zeit
es wäre schon cool wenn sie wenigstens
eine Toilette hätten gestern war ich mit
meinem Kind hier und das hat es kaum
noch ausgehalten
in den Glauben an die Unbesiegbarkeit
schnell auf die Probe viel ist schon
gestritten worden um den landesweiten
Aufbau von 4000 solcher Wärmestuben mit
denen die Menschen den Winter überstehen
sollen und ihm sie fürchten er könnte
der schlimmste werden seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
wir haben hier warme ge und auch viele
Medikamente
die Leute können Kontakt zu Angehörigen
halten und bleiben gut informiert weil
sie bei uns Ihre handys aufladen können
wir haben sogar eine Spielecke damit es
den Kindern nicht langweilig wird
der Alltag im Krieg erfordert seine ganz
eigene Kreativität dicke Decken sollen
die Tiefkühlkost retten in der
Gefriertruhe von Anjas kleinem Laden
gerade gibt es mal wieder Strom die
Hoffnung dass das lange so bleibt ist
nicht groß an der gibt sich alle Mühe
ihren Laden irgendwie am Laufen zu
halten eine Herausforderung in die
Versorgung dauern zusammenbricht
Dusche die Heizung funktioniert schon
seit Tagen wieder nicht ich war gerade
erst krank und lag mit fast 40 Fieber im
Bett danach ging die Heizung zwar aber
nach kurzer Zeit kam wieder nur kalte
Luft
in dieser Mangelwirtschaft spricht sich
schnell herum wo es gerade Strom gibt
die Juri ein Stammkunde von Anja will
nichts kaufen was er braucht ist eine
funktionierende Steckdose für sein Handy
während das auflädt wartet er draußen in
der Feuchtigkeiten Luft
ich habe Angst dass es noch kälter wird
im Fernsehen sagen sie wir sollen uns
Heizlüfter kaufen aber es gibt ja kaum
Strom dann raten Sie uns einen Ofen zu
beschaffen aber wo soll ich in meiner
Wohnung einen Ofen hinstellen das geht
nicht ich weiß nicht was ich tun soll
wir werden uns wohl dick anziehen und
uns unter die Bettdecke verkriechen
Alex Tina zweifelt nicht dass ihr Land
siegen wird sie kämpft gegen die Russen
am eigenen Backofen sobald der Strom mal
wieder da ist bereitet sie Kekse für die
ukrainischen Soldaten mehr als 7000 hat
sie schon für die Truppe gebacken
verziert mit dem Schlachthof russisches
Kriegsschiff verzieh dich nicht mal der
Zusammenbruch der Wasserversorgung
konnte sie stoppen muss schon
mein Mann ist jeden Tag losgegangen um
Wasser zu besorgen das hat ganz gut
geklappt denn eineinhalb oder zwei
Monate hatten wir überhaupt kein Wasser
in der Leitung
jetzt haben wir wieder was dass wir
wenigstens zum Spülen und Waschen
verwenden können
Wasserleitungen mit salzigem Wasser aus
den Meer seitdem die Russen die
Versorgung aus dem Fluss geklappt haben
Trinkwasser gibt es nur noch an
öffentlichen Verteilstationen
wir lassen uns nicht unterkriegen wir
haben keine Angst ganz gleich ob Hunger
oder Kälte wir halten das alles aus
den Hunger vertreiben solche
Durchhalteparolen natürlich nicht der
Krieg hat auch ein nikolaje viele um
ihren Job gebracht Ersparnisse sind
längst aufgezerrt es werden immer mehr
die auf Lebensmittel Spenden angewiesen
sind das ist alles furchtbar es gibt
kaum Jobs man findet oft nur schlecht
bezahlte Aushilfstätigkeiten
in der Brotfabrik Nummer eins gibt es
noch etwas zu tun hier backen Sie
täglich bis zu 30.000 Brote die sie in
der Stadt und dem Umland verteilen das
Geld kommt auch von internationalen
Hilfsorganisationen 20 Tonnen schieben
sich jede Nacht durch die
Produktionsstraßen vor dem Krieg waren
es bis zu siebenmal so viel
für uns kann jeder Tag der letzte sein
wir wissen ja nicht was morgen passiert
wenn wir ins Bett gehen haben wir keine
Ahnung wie wir aufwachen werden
wir halten das alles aus für unser
Vaterland wir können ja nirgendwohin
also werden wir überleben es gibt ja
keine Alternative
davon ist auch Straßenbahnfahrerin
Holländer überzeugt immer noch wartet
sie in ihrer Tram auf Strom damit sie
zurück ins Depot fahren kann morgen
wollen sie alle wieder zeigen wie
unbesiegbar Nikolajew ist